Let's imagine I have 20 of these games. Okay?
>> Sure.
>> So I'm going to play these games 20 times in
a row. Now what you've been doing is you've been
going forward. You've said, well, if I can get us
the right thing or if I can basically threaten you and
say. If you screw me over this time, I'll screw
you over from now on. Then maybe I can get you
to do the right thing and vice versa, since it's
a symmetric game. And then we'll end up doing the right
thing all along. And that makes a lot of sense, right?
>> Yeah.
>> If you're going forward. But what
if you're going backward, Michael? Let's imagine
we are doing [CROSSTALK]. What is amazing
to me is that is exactly backwards what
you just said. So, let's imagine we are doing these 20 dot dot dot dot,
and now I'm on the 20th game, okay? What's going to happen on the 20th game?
>> Well, I mean, I guess I could have built up
trust in you from the previous games and
think that you're going to cooperate with me, because we've
been cooperating together. And then that would be
the perfect time to drop a dime on you.
>> Exactly. So, if this is the 20th game and we're
in this situation, remember whatever value we've been adding up along
the way, that's sunk cost. Right. The
only thing that's left is the final game. And the final game looks like this,
which means we're going to end up here.
But guess what, Michael? The final one is
determined. So since we already know the outcome
of the final game, the only one that
we, the next one that we can look at is the 19th game. Well, we already
know what the outcome of the final game
is. So this is effectively the last game.
>> Oh.
>> And what is the outcome of that
going to be? It's going to be this and backwards,
backwards, backwards, backwards proof by induction because
the only that proves computer scientists know
how to do is proof by induction. It turns out that we will always defect
>> For what it's worth, those are the only proofs worth doing. But, okay.
>> That's true. It's a fine point. Truth by induction and
perhaps by conduction [LAUGH]. So, there you go Michael, even if I
can play multiple, multiple games to try to build up trust,
the truth is the Nash equilibrium, if I filled out that eight
by eight matrix you wanted me to fill out. I would still
end up in the same place where I would defect both times.
>> Certainly if, yeah okay, so if you're going to be a jerk then, then I
have to be a jerk, but yeah, I
guess that's right. That's, that seems pretty horrible.
>> It is. And by the way this is not
just something I'm making up. This is another theorem that
comes out of Nash equilibrium. That if you have an
n repeated game then the solution is n repeated, Nash
equilibrium. So whatever the Nash equilibrium is
for the first game, the one version
of the game, is the repeated Nash equilibrium for all versions of that game.
>> Okay, wait a, hang on, hang on. So I. Okay, I buy that.
>> Mm-hm.
>> But couldn't you, well so, in a game that
has more than one Nash equilibrium, couldn't we like, al, alternate?
>> We could, and in fact you'll notice that in so far,
I have not talked about the case where you have multiple Nash equilibrium.
Because in fact, that's it's own problem. If I have one
Nash equilibrium, then we know what's going to happen. If I have two
Nash equilibria, which one do we choose? Now, what's important to know
here, is that if we have two Nash Equilibria then that means
that if you're in any one of them, you won't leave
it. So it's not like you'll move from one Nash Equilibrium to
another, sort of in the general case. Because the fact that it's
an equilibrium means that if everyone else is fixed except one person,
that person won't choose to move. But. I haven't said anything about how you
would choose among multiple Nash equilibria. And
that's beyond the scope of this class.
>> Okay.
>> But it is an active researcher and in fact
some of my own students have done some work in
thinking about. What it would mean to choose and actually
the answer always boils down to, let's not worry about that.
>> [LAUGH] All right. But I'm still kind of disturbed
by this, right? So it seems like it's sort of saying, is if we
knew the world was going to end tomorrow then we might as well be greedy
bastards. And, in fact, if we know that the world is going to end at
any particular time, which of course it
will. We might as well be greedy bastards.
>> That's right. So, be greedy bastards.
>> Oh, no!
>> Or at least, or at least be you know, Nash bastards.
>> [LAUGH] We'll, the Nash is kind of greedy right, it's like I'm always
taking an action that's always best for me.
>> Yes, you are.
>> No.
>> Every single thing we've talked about today. Has always
assumed that you're always doing what's best for you. The fact
that it might also be best for someone else is
neither here nor there, you're always doing what's best for you.
>> Right, I get, I get that, but it's, it sounds like this argument is saying
that we might as well be like that, like all the time and never really form,
like never, never self-sacrifice even a little
bit for greater advantage even to yourself.
>> Well, that's not true. This, it's just
all hidden in the utilities, once you've gone through
all the what I'm going to do today, what
I'm going to do tomorrow, you add it all up,
whatever the right strategy is to take. That's
the strategy that you take because it's already accounted
for all the self-sacrfice you might do that then
leads to later good deeds or later good outcome.
So the wonderful thing about all of this, is that this
matrix is everything you need to know. It captures the future, past
and everything else, so everything you need to know is right
here. And it's all been reduced to a bunch of pairs of
numbers. But you did say something kind of interesting though, Michael,
which I think is worth pointing out, which is that everything you
say requires knowing when, at least in this sort of iterated version,
requires knowing when the world is going to end. So an interesting question
to ask would be, what would happen if I knew the world
was going to end but I didn't know when. Would that change my behavior.
>> It, it doesn't seem like that
should make any difference because it's still
going to end. If not today then tomorrow. Or if not tomorrow then the next day.
>> True. But I bet yeah it does make a difference.
>> I'm willing to go and think about that.
>> Okay, why don't you go think about it and let me know.
>> Alright. I'll, I'll tell you about it in the next lecture then.
>> Okay, I like that. Excellent. Okay, cool. So,
let's move on.
>> [LAUGH] Okay, fair enough.